good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast 400 pounds for every
household and more for the eight million
families who need it most that the
centerpiece of the chancellor's 21
billion pound announcement yesterday all
part of his attempt to try and ease the
cost of living crisis the help has been
warmly received but there has been some
criticism over how it will be paid for
in part by windfall tax on oil and gas
companies in just a moment i'll be
joined by the chancellor rishi sunak and
later in the programme we'll be hearing
from his labour opposite number the
shadow chancellor rachel reeves it is
friday 27th of may
help for struggling families as the
chancellor moves to tackle the cost of
living crisis
every household will get 400 pounds with
more for those on the lowest incomes i'm
in york to find out what sort of impact
it's going to have on people
here in texas police say they will
investigate their own response time to
the shooting which killed 19
young children and as they do up the
road in houston the country's biggest
pro-gun lobby will hold its annual
convention with special guest donald
trump
in nottingham the nhs trust warned to
make urgent improvements over safety
fears for mothers and babies
ukraine appeals for more weapons sky
news witnesses the desperate battle to
stay alive in the cellars under the city
on the bank of falling to russian forces
this has been going on
this has been going on all morning
there are lots and lots of residents
still living here
not so happy travels passengers have
warned they could face major delays as
airports struggle to cope with the
half-time rush
also ahead on the programme i'll be
joined by father dougal himself that's
the actor and comic ardolo hanlon he'll
be speaking about his new novel set on
the irish border during that uneasy
transition to peace
and andy fletcher kearbordist founding
member of the legendary british group
peshmerga has died at the age
[Music]
morning all as the cost of living
continues to soar the chancellor has
made a well significant intervention to
help struggling families rishi sunak
unveiled a new set of measures including
a one-off payment of 650 pounds for 8
million households it will be paid for
in part
by u-turn over a windfall tax on oil and
gas companies let's take a look at some
of the key announcements that emerged
from the chancellor yesterday
a rebate on energy and gas bills for
every household will be doubled from 200
pounds to 400 pounds another big change
of course it would now have to be repaid
there'll be a new one off 650 pounds
cost of living payment for the 8 million
households with the lowest incomes
a one-off payment of 300 pounds will be
given to pensioners
and there will be 150 pounds for people
receiving disability benefits all of
which will be funded in part
by a 25 windfall tax on oil and gas
firms that is expected to raise five
billion pounds
and as you can see the chancellor richie
soon act joins us in the studio lovely
to see you this morning chancellor a
busy day for you yesterday and a number
of kind of very eye-catching policy
announcements particularly those
targeted at the bottom end but we just
start with with the windfall tax
why the u-turn it certainly felt for for
for some time that the treasury was
resisting this tax on oil and gas
companies
well i've always approached this as a
pragmatist my view is we wanted to find
a way that we could tax these profits
fairly which i think is the right thing
to do given the circumstances of a war
leading to very high prices which are
leading to excessive profits but i
wanted to do that in a way which would
continue to incentivize investment and
that's why we've taken the time to get
this right and our version of this
contains a very generous incentive for
businesses to continue investing so that
the more investment they make the less
tax they pay and that's good for us it's
good for the economy that's good for
british jobs and it's good for our
energy security and that was a balance
that we wanted to get right so and
that's what we announced yesterday so
how much in total is this this all going
to cost i mean the figure put out by the
treasury started at 15 billion yesterday
and was then revised upwards to 21
billion no the what we announced
yesterday was 15 billion pounds of new
support to help people with the cost of
living but six billion then from the
spring statement from from the yes
i've not mentioned that figure i've very
specifically said what we announced
yesterday was 15 billion pounds worth of
support to help with the cost of living
with the most vulnerable
households which is the third of all
households in the uk are receiving help
worth around 1 200 pounds but there's
also support available for everyone
because we promised we would stand by
the british people at this time and
yesterday that's what we did why now why
not in the in the spring statement i
mean this idea of a windfall tax has
been kicking around for for several
months now well on on the
the levy that we're putting on energy
companies as i said we wanted to take
the time to get that right so we could
also incentivize investment that is a
very different feature of how we're
doing it's an important one and i think
it was important to take the time to get
that right but why now that's a
perfectly fair question i've always been
consistent and i've said since the
spring earlier in the spring that i was
prepared to do more and we would do more
but it was right to wait until we had
some more certainty about what would
happen to energy bills in the autumn
they're the biggest driver of the
increase in responsibility if i could
just finish they're the biggest driver
of the cost of living and it wasn't
until this week we heard from ofgem who
are the regulator that sets those prices
that we now have a bit of clarity about
that and that meant i could size the
support appropriately yeah okay but the
office for budget responsibility pointed
out in the spring statement that the
energy cap could be rising by october to
2800 and the information was already
there no and the key thing is could and
the the office budget responsibility are
not the independent regulator that set
the energy price cap they're one of many
people who have a view on what it might
have been and the reality is the price
cap is set over a period from february
through to the summer so it simply isn't
the case that anyone had any good idea
about what it was at the beginning of
that period now we're further through we
do have a good idea we heard from the
regulator on tuesday i think it was
from offgem and we've acted i think
quite quickly in making sure that we can
provide support and give people
reassurance do you understand why
several of your colleagues and quite
high profile colleagues have suggested
this is not a particularly conservative
announcement i mean you had
the head of the ifs quoted in the times
today saying gordon brown would be
pleased with this particular
announcement given how we distributed
this today well i think when we're
dealing as a country with the type of
challenge that we now face with
inflation running where it is
i think the right response from a
compassionate conservative government is
as we have done by the past two years to
stand by people at a time of need and
that's why it's particularly important
that those most vulnerable get the most
support that's what you saw yesterday
but we also recognize that with bills
going up on this scale everyone is going
to feel the pinch and that's why we
wanted to make sure that there was
support available for everyone on a more
universal basis 400 pounds this autumn
on top of the 150 pounds council tax
rebate that has already gone in place
you know i think that's the right
balance but we've also done it in a
responsible way by helping to raise
money to pay for some of the measures of
course this not being a budget we didn't
have the kind of the detail that you
might might usually get the office for
budget responsibility hasn't been able
to go through it so some specific
questions on costing that you i
presumably have done
what effect does the treasury think that
this will have on on inflation well as
you said that will be a matter for the
office for budget responsibility you
must have done your own when they do
their formal independent uh
review and analysis i think it's
our estimate my view is that it will
have a minimal impact on inflation and
that's for two what do you mean by
minimum
one percentage point no much much much
less than that minimal and the reason
for that is twofold one is that because
what we're doing is very targeted at
those most in need and and secondly
because we're also raising money to help
pay for it the combination of those two
things is the responsible approach
because even though we are as you said
supporting the economy we want to make
sure that we don't make the inflation
situation worse and you know doing what
some people might say is you should just
spend even more or borrow even more i
think that would be irresponsible
because that would risk driving up
inflation interest rates and people's
mortgages and that's not something that
i think we should be doing sure but you
you say that it's targeted at most at
most in need i do wonder then why you
haven't means tested the 400 pounds
payment i i'm going to be slightly
challenged i will not be the only person
who makes this point this morning it was
just a week ago that you and your wife
appeared in the sunday times rich list
you know fast forward to yesterday and
the most eye-catching policy that you
announced yesterday to you know to
target those who are most in need ends
up with both you and i ending up 400
pounds better off i mean we don't need
the money well so in terms of look at
the overall package that we announced
yesterday three quarters of the funding
is going to the most vulnerable
households and pensions right but let's
talk about the questions
the scale of the four hundred percent so
i'm going to receive yes
and you and i don't need it but actually
lots and lots and lots of people why are
we receiving anything because
when you're trying to help people on
that scale when you need to get help to
tens of millions of people right
actually you've got a choice how best
can you deliver that and the reality is
when you're talking about that number of
people there really aren't many ways to
do it and we wanted to make sure that
this was as universal as possible we had
another alternative of doing that which
was a council tax rebate which is where
you can try and
exclude people right at the top in very
large houses but you know what we tried
that and we tried to do it with a
discretionary fund and it's worked
reasonably well but there are lots of
cases of people who will say hang on i
happen to live in this you know
expensive looking house or in a high
council tax ban house but i need help
too so actually
this being universal means that we avoid
all of those problems and really do get
help to everyone who needs it and you
like me if i'm sure like me you can also
give that money to charity if you don't
need it and that's that's great which
which is great but you know it strikes
me that rich people didn't get rich by
handing back free money that they
received from the government it's good
for you that you're going to donate it
to charity a wedge or most people who
receive it won't
oh well i'm done most people i'm sure
you will and set an example but i said
if i think it's incumbent on someone to
say well here's the alternative
how would you else how else would you
get the support to those on middle
incomes who are working hard who do feel
they need support and i hear a lot from
them every week just because they're not
on benefits or they don't and they're
not pensioners they still actually think
this is tough for me it's a 1 200 pound
increase in my energy bill it's right
that the government's on my side and i
do want to be on the side of those
people if there's another way to help
those people whilst figuring out the the
smaller minority of very wealthy people
who don't need it i would be very open
to it but actually when you're trying to
deliver support in my job practically to
tens of millions of people you've got to
just figure out how best to do that and
i do think this is the right way one of
the the electricity generators a lot of
people were suspecting that they may
well have been included in the windfall
tax they weren't i'm just trying to
understand why well what we said if you
look at the language i use and i was
very precise about this you know it is
the case that there are we think
extraordinary profits being made in that
sector as a result again of elevated gas
prices because of the war in ukraine but
what we want to do and we are going to
do urgently is understand the scale of
those profits and then decide on the
appropriate next step so they're going
to have to cough up at some point just
not yet but we do have plans in place to
reform that market so other countries in
europe like france italy spain portugal
greece have all taken steps to reform
that market to correct that now we have
a plan to do the same thing so what
we're sitting down now is figuring out
well how quickly can that be put in
place and in the interim what would be
the appropriate steps just one final
question on what we had yesterday in
terms of pensions and benefits if
inflation gets to 10 or or even higher
what is your estimate of how much more
we will have it be having to pay in
terms of pensions and benefits ed conway
did a little bit of a kind of a back of
a [ __ ] packet calculation yesterday and
he came up with a figure we can bring it
up here of around about 25 billion
pounds worth of additional expenditure
is he in the ballpark
well actually you talked about the
office for budget responsibility who are
our independent forecaster in the spring
statement they have already included the
impact of pensions and benefits next
year going up by a relatively large
amount relative to inflation is that is
that bigger i mean it's not bigger i
precisely recognized but actually the
numbers that we have do assume that that
happens and that actually should give
people reassurance that next year
actually their pensions and benefits
will be rising well in excess of what
inflation is currently forecasted to be
the support we've provided yesterday
will help bridge people from here to
there and i think it will be very
significant it's meaningful and will
make an enormous difference particularly
to those most vulnerable in our society
i bet you thought you were going to get
through an interview without talking
about parties and dining strip i'm
afraid we we have to um one thing that
that has been striking a lot of people
myself included
in terms of the prime minister's defence
is that he felt that it was necessary
for him to attend leaving parties for
members of his staff
why
well i i think the prime minister has
has rightly
explained his actions and taken full
responsibility for everything that
happened in downing street he's
apologized profusely for it and i think
most importantly as well has as he said
just the other day learnt the lessons
from what's happened and made changes
and i see that because it's also a
building where i work and he's made
significant changes to how downing
street runs which is the right thing to
do and he has and he's actually
committed and he's more determined about
delivering for the british people
his defense has been that he felt that
it was part of the job to pitch up and
and say goodbye to people who are
leaving leaving town
i just wonder what planet the prime
minister's on in the middle of a viral
pandemic no one else was doing that i
spent a year siloed away from the people
who work on this very program i saw a
security guard i saw a floor manager and
i saw the lady who cleans our studio for
about the best part of a year that was
it and i'm not running the country the
prime minister went from meeting of
cobra meeting of cabinet meeting with
advisors partying the flat a leaving do
i mean this was at a time of a viral
pandemic why was the prime minister
putting himself in harm's way in that
fashion well
these these matters have all been now
fully looked at by both sue gray
independently and also by the police
they've reached all their conclusions
the prime minister's apologized and made
a statement and importantly now made
changes in how downing street runs i do
think that's the right approach and he
has my full support in carrying on now
and delivering for the british people
richie sooner good to have you in the
studio thanks for joining us
uh let's have a quick look at the papers
and as you might expect plenty of
coverage uh about the chancellor's
announcement yesterday
well after that cost of living health
health package announcement in the
commons the eyes headline every home to
get 400 pounds cut in energy bills
uh the metro puts it thus i think the
chance will be pleased with this one
rishi to the rescue well maybe not the
last two words at last
and the express uh reads rishi's twelve
hundred pounds boost for eight million
people
and the telegraph leads with mr sumac's
claim that the tories are now a party of
big spending and generosity
similarly the mail calls the plan a
splurge
uh well the mirror puts it pretty
straightforwardly about time rishi
uh but the guardian says that mr sunai
finally bowed to months of pressure over
the cost of living crisis after a
bruising week for the government their
words
let's stick with those cost of living
measures announced by the chancellor
skies fraser mode joining us from yacht
market good to see you this morning
fraser and look lots of money sloshing
around lots of it targeted
at those most in need but the question
as i put it to the chancellor was well
why do it now why didn't you do it
months ago
exactly i think that's what a lot of
people are thinking today in terms of
what they're going to get everyone is
going to benefit from this in some way
some obviously more than others
particularly those uh on in lower income
households eight million lower income
households will get a much larger share
of the pot that's uh that's been created
by this windfall tax on the on the
energy firms i don't think too many
people are too bothered about where the
money's coming from we've heard jacob
rees-mogg saying that there is no such
thing as an an economically free
tax breaks such as this there will be
repercussions somewhere later down the
line i don't think people are too
worried about that because they're
worried about the here and now we've
seen food prices soaring because of the
crisis in ukraine we know that energy
prices are soaring food prices petrol at
the pump and diesel at the pump those
costs are going through the roof as well
and everybody is beginning to uh to feel
the pinch the the amount that people are
spending on their energy bills it was
the highest since the 1950s up until
these measures were introduced now
they've been introduced it's still the
highest since the 1980s and people are
still concerned about what that's going
to mean further on down the line the
energy cap has been increased it's
possible that that could be increased
yet further as we as we move uh towards
the the latter part of the year and into
the area where people do need those
those fuel uh the the help with the fuel
costs even more in terms of um
in terms of what people are going to uh
to do with this uh it's been done on an
in on a universal basis as rishi sunak
was explaining to you earlier he said
that seemed to be the fairest way to do
it they were thinking about trying to do
some sort of means-tested system based
on council tax and so on but basically
this is a universal
boost to everybody which means there
will be people who don't necessarily
need this is that wasted money could
they return it will they return it
that's highly unlikely uh one would say
and the cbi are also saying that this uh
that this uh announcement could
potentially discourage investment
particularly in companies who are trying
to strive towards uh cleaner energy and
and zero carbon emissions so there are
potential drawbacks i don't think the
man in the street the woman in the
streets are particularly bothered about
those potential financial drawbacks in
terms of business investments at the
moment what they're worried about is the
money in their pocket and this obviously
is going to give them a bit more of that
whether it's going to be enough whether
it's going to keep people away from the
food banks whether it's going to keep
people out of fuel poverty
is yet to be seen it's unlikely given
the fact that we've got inflation
running at nine percent in the bank of
england saying that that could well get
worse
phrase up for thanks very much indeed
all right police in the small texas town
of vivaldi are facing growing criticism
over their handling of the school
shooting that left 19 children
and two teachers dead it's a marriage
that the gunman entered the school
without any confrontation with the
authorities and was inside for as long
as an hour before police stormed in
despite appeals from bystanders to go in
soon after the shooting began this comes
as the biggest u.s gun lobby the
national rifle association has vowed to
press on with its annual meeting in
houston roughly a four-hour drive from
louisville
mark stone has this report
in the quiet heart of a small town
ripped apart there are now 21 crosses
that you value me back to normal where
they can trust the good god because you
are a good god and a faith that must now
carry a broken community and we believe
that you value is destined to be a city
of glory
among them parents who know it could
have been their children
and then how do you explain all this to
them
over the street in the calm of his
office one among so many who witnessed
such horror this photo here was you yeah
was this yesterday
that was this morning this morning
and what what was hap what was happening
here it was just it was just a tough
time a moment
eulalio diaz is the official whose job
it became to identify the young victims
this is not normal life this is not the
way it's supposed to happen my job is to
be a corner for the county when it's
needed but never for 21
people that were
massacred at a school that's not what i
signed up to do that's not what i
expected to do but i have to do it
alongside all the grief for the
questions about guns and the gunman of
course but the police response to and
security at the school
he walked in uninstructed initially so
from
the grandmother's house to the barbadge
to the school
into the school
he was not confronted by anybody
officers revealed the school's back door
might have been unlocked
for the families who pleaded with police
to go into the school as it all unfolded
they have promised a full investigation
and now tragedy upon tragedy irma garcia
was one of the two teachers shot with
her pupils
her husband joe has since suffered a
fatal heart attack
they were high school sweethearts and
married for 24 years
they leave behind four children
mark stone sky news in texas
coming up on the program this morning as
the chancellor sets his plan it sets out
his plan to ease the pressure on
households i'll be speaking to the chief
economist at the resolution foundation
think tank
about whether the measures will be
enough
also this i'll take a look at how the
current monkey pox outbreak may have
originated i will be speaking to an
expert in biodiversity
and in the next hour having heard from
the chancellor we will be healing from
his opposite number of the shadow
chancellor rachel
uh but let's take you through some of
the day's other headlines now and six
soldiers have been arrested on suspicion
of conspiracy to supply drugs and money
laundering offences the irish guard
soldiers whose headquarters are in west
london were arrested in an operation led
by the royal military police the
ministry of defence says those involved
will not be taking part in the queen's
platinum jubilee events
the last remaining covert restrictions
in wales are expected to be lifted from
monday
first minister mark drakeford is due to
announce the plans a little later today
since moving to covet alert level zero
in january remaining measures have
included the use of face coverings in
health settings and the requirements to
take a lateral flow test upon developing
developing symptoms
tributes have been paid to the
goodfellas actor rayleigh otter who's
died aged 67.
they have to made his name playing
real-life mobster henry hill in martin
scorsese's critically acclaimed movie
it's understood he passed away in his
sleep in the dominican republic where he
was filming a new movie
the uk's crown prosecution service has
said the actor kevin spacey has been
charged with four counts of sexual
assault against three men the alleged
incidents took place in london between
march 2005 and august 2008
and in gloucestershire in april 2013.
now the healthcare regulator has issued
a safety warning to an nhs trust
embroiled in a scandal over baby deaths
the care quality commission told
nottingham university hospital's nhs
trust it must make significant and
immediate improvements to its maternity
services as it admitted women and babies
may not be safe
correspondent emma birchley is at
nottingham city hospital for us this
morning good to see you emma just
explain exactly what this intervention
by the cqc practically means for the
hospital
well it's hugely concerning that's for
sure it follows unannounced uh visits by
the health regulator
in march and they found that yet again
the maternity services being offered
are inadequate
and that while staff
are working hard
there are simply not enough of them they
are not always well enough trained and
this is an absolutely key point that
mothers are not being checked often
enough to make sure that their condition
isn't deteriorating and all of this
follows the announcements last night
that the senior midwife donna ockendon
had been appointed to lead a brand new
inquiry into exactly what has happened
here hundreds of families have come
forward with complaints dozens of babies
are known to have died all been left
seriously injured
and now uh donna rockington who led the
similar inquiry in shrewsbury which
found that more two more than 200 babies
had died as a result of failings there
will lead this new inquiry and the
families say they have an immense sense
of relief that that is uh the case they
have pushed for this uh with the
government um and they have enormous
complaints about what has been happening
here another review which happened last
summer which was still underway has now
been stopped so the families will be
hoping that they finally get the answers
that they want
they certainly will emma thank you
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
has warned in his address last night
that the current offensive by russia in
the donbass could make the region
uninhabitable he also called the
killings of civilians a clear politic of
genocide
policy of genocide conducted by russia
from the city of severo donetsk our
special correspondent alex crawford
reports
there's nowhere to run and very few
places to hide in the besieged city of
cebra donetsk
they cook food on fires in the open
power and running water stopped weeks
ago
but it's always done within easy reach
of their underground shelter
to descend down here is to enter a truly
grim dank and perpetually dark place
desperation and despair stalk the
concrete corridors and disease runs riot
there's a shame here amongst the
residents a real embarrassment about
being reduced to this
there are nearly a hundred people living
on top of one another twenty feet
underground the only place they feel
offers them some chance of survival from
the bombings above
they've had an outbreak of tuberculosis
people have caught pneumonia in here
hygiene's obviously extremely hard in
these terribly cramped conditions and we
hear constant coughing and wretching
sheets of cardboard are used as
separation but they offer scant privacy
and all this is all they have salvaged
from their lives
life has a post-apocalyptic feel about
it down here but still some display a
steely determination to come through
this
[Music]
i must
survive i don't think about those
sharings bombings explosions and so on
and so forth i just wanna i just
have to or even musk
i must survive
there's a half hour when the generator
is switched on and they have power
there's a rush to charge phones used for
light
and to take the chance to maintain some
self-care
but it also means they can pump water
and stock up on supplies
tanya goes round the shelter telling
everyone this is the final opportunity
to get out of several dinettes
this is the last chance for evacuation
she says think about it but no one here
is ready to flee their home city despite
the obvious dangers many here have had
access only to russian propaganda and
believe they're liberating them
there's intense bombardment russian
troops are at the city gates and on the
cusp of circling it
it seems only a matter of time
has been going on
this has been going on all morning there
are lots and lots of residents still
living here a lot of them old people and
having to run in and out of this just to
cook or to fetch water it is relentless
the russians are bombing street by
street in their efforts to capture this
city blasting houses and homes which
stand in their path they have the
momentum now
and the destruction is immense
taking sevra donetsk would mean the
whole of the lhansk region falls to
russian control
maria and ivan have lived here all their
married lives now they're outdoor
kitchens amongst the world's most
dangerous
they've just got food scraps and blame
both sides for targeting civilians
[Laughter]
[Music]
come on come on says maria this is so
hard for the elderly who don't
understand why there's a war over
donbass at all
maria urges ivan to clear space for us
to shelter they're more worried about
our safety
this is what their days are like now
dodging explosions and separated from
their grandchildren
and they feel they've been badly let
down by their city leaders
um
[Applause]
so far they've been lucky but they've
come close
but the real hurt is in the family
separation
the city already looks smashed to pieces
but there are thousands of civilians
still inside and the russians show no
signs of stopping their barrage yet
alex crawford sky news inside sevra
donetsk in the donbass eastern ukraine
now air passengers could face travel
chaos over half term because airports
are still struggling to find enough
staff to cope with the surge in demand
since of course uh all covered
restrictions were lifted skies becky
johnson reports now from birmingham
airport
since restrictions on travel were lifted
demand has soared
terminals have been filling up with
passengers keen to go on holiday it's
nice to get away for a change that we
haven't been away since before covered
yeah of course everyone wants to get
away
airports have struggled with the numbers
of people have your boarding passes
ready just to scan
thank you
at times they've been cues out of the
doors the main issue a shortage of staff
now half term and the bank holiday
weekend will be the next big tests for
the first time in more than two years
passenger numbers are starting to
resemble what they did before the
pandemic but that's bringing its own set
of challenges
almost half the staff here at birmingham
airport were made redundant during the
pandemic
now passengers are back they've
struggled to recruit quickly enough for
a period of time you know we haven't
been an attractive industry for people
to feel safe to come and work for us
because what happens if it happens again
now a few months in people are wanting
to apply and work for us and we're
seeing lots of people
being recruited unfortunately to do
security clearance takes time it can
take up to two months to get security
clears before we can really start
training these people did you get your
passports and boarding cards ready it
means everyone's working overtime
including the chief executive
3 am come along join the team in
security so i'm there helping out
loading trays and it could be like this
for months we expect the summer to be
really busy we'll be largely back in
where we want to be through the middle
of august in terms of getting ourselves
back to normal fully would probably be
september october
but that shouldn't deter anybody from
traveling through birmingham airport in
the meantime
the plea to passengers is come prepared
to be patient
as an industry grounded for so long gets
going once again becky johnson sky news
birmingham
that's some sad news this andy fletcher
fletch as he was better known a
keyboardist and founding member of the
legendary group depeche mode well he's
died at the age of 60.
just can't get enough you cannot fail to
recognize that from just the first
opening at lyrics uh well the band was
formed in basildon in essex back in
1980.
in a statement his band mate said this
fletch of a true heart of gold and was
always there when you needed support a
lively conversation a good laugh or a
cold pint it'd be sadly missed
now in the last half an hour the
chancellor told this program that his
plans to ease the cost of living crisis
will have a minimal impact on inflation
rishi sunak suggested the targeted
nature of the measures he announced
yesterday was the responsible approach
in the face of rising prices
that will be a matter for the office for
budget responsibilities you must have
done your own when they do their formal
independent uh
review and analysis i think it's
our estimate my view is that it will
have a minimal impact on inflation and
that's for two what do you mean by
minimum
one percentage point no
much much less than that minimal and the
reason for that is twofold one is that
because what we're doing is very
targeted at those most in need
and and secondly because we're also
raising money to help pay for it the
combination of those two things is the
responsible approach because even though
we are as you said supporting the
economy we want to make sure that we
don't make the inflation situation worse
and you know doing what some people
might say is you should just spend even
more or borrow even more i think that
would be irresponsible because that
would risk driving up inflation interest
rates and people's mortgages and that's
not something that i think we should be
doing
as always ron powell was uh lacking in
the wings listening into that chat with
the chancellor joins us now good to see
you this morning rob um what left out at
you i mean clearly uh the chancellor
suggesting that your inflation problem
rip your inflationary pressures will be
minimal i suspect will reassure some
people not everyone though yeah i
thought how confident he was about that
um leapt out quite a bit especially
because a lot of the concerns
ideologically anyway within the
conservative party of deciding to do
this not only raising the money through
a windfall tax but to spend it directly
by giving people money rather than say
doing tax cuts is that it would have the
overall effect of making prices rise
even further almost setting himself a
target there of saying that he thinks it
will be less than one percentage point
that this impacts um inflation as well i
thought a very heavy hint that actually
there might be an expansion of something
around this windfall tax scheme to
electricity generating companies as well
he said they need to understand what's
going on in that sector but talked about
extraordinary profits that they thought
were there so that there's been some
coverage of that this week and so that
looks likely to happen as well also as
well a defense of the more universal
aspect of this in terms of 400 pounds
for everyone yeah because the chance on
on a couple of other policies has seemed
as if he doesn't like means testing but
he he did spend some length trying to
explain it today yeah he basically said
it's similar to the the support schemes
in the pa in the pandemic when a lot of
money was going to people that didn't
necessarily need it but the problem is
is that to get the money to those that
do in a fast enough way you have to
accept that some money is going to go to
those that don't need it and you
essentially get into the argument around
the winter fuel allowance of rich
pensioners using it to heat their
swimming pools rishi soon act telling
you that he'd be giving his money um to
charity and saying other people can do
that as well also as well all but
confirming that benefits and pensions
would be rising as he did yesterday by 9
10 by the current inflation figure next
year and talking about this support as a
bridge to that point now
that suggests that he doesn't
necessarily think he'll have to come
back and do any more he's built that
bridge um already i think we'll see yeah
we certainly will rob for now thanks
very much indeed
uh but let's stick with the chancellor's
plans get a little bit more reaction uh
joining us on the program at mike brewer
chief economist at the resolution
foundation think tank mike lovely to see
you this morning um so simple question
what did you make of it
oh i'm really pleased to see the
chancellor step up recognize the scale
of the problem caused by high energy
prices and and come in with a really
substantial package and really
importantly i think a package which was
uh skewed towards those households which
are going to be struggling from the high
cost of energy this winter so a
progressive package where i think he was
making up for perhaps some of the
emissions in what we had at the spring
statement
yeah indeed i mean when the ifs suggests
that you know the poorest in society may
have you know pretty much most of the
additional cost of living covered by the
announcement yesterday that's always
going to please the chancellor i suppose
the problem is is you know this will
involve significant amounts of borrowing
again for the chancellor to be able to
make the books balance
well i think there's two two important
things to remember first of all the
chancellor directed a lot of money to
those people on benefits and in doing so
he was really i think just trying to
correct
a mistake he made earlier this year when
he let benefits go up by much less than
a rate of inflation so a great deal of
the money announced yesterday was really
just filling in making sure that
benefits are keeping up with inflation
and and secondly um almost about all the
15 billion pounds announced yesterday
was a one-off uh we've got one-off uh
discount on our energy bill and we've
got these one-off payments to benefit
and state pension recipients this summer
and so they're not going to have a
permanent impact on the level of
borrowing um and of course it's right
that when crises hit whether that be a
pandemic or whether that be a surge in
the cost of living of essentials it's
right that the government borrows to
help households through that
it's still the resolution foundation
research that i was reading this morning
does suggest that the the the group that
are the biggest group to lose out are
our families with children just explain
exactly what that might be
well the chancellor decided to use uh
lump sum payments to benefit and state
pension recipients to to get you know to
get us through the the winter coming up
so the amounts there are fixed is the
same amount uh 650 pounds for anybody on
a means-tested benefit uh regardless of
whether you are a single young person on
universal credit or whether you are say
a family with three or four children you
still just get that 650 pounds
but of course we know that larger
families are going to live in larger
houses their energy bills are much
higher and their energy bills are going
up by much more
and our calculations were that a family
with three children they're going to see
their energy bills go up by 500 pounds
more than a single person or mean says
it benefits yet they're all getting the
same 650 pounds
given that
the broad expectation is that things are
definitely going to get worse before
they get better and it'll be quite some
time before things get better
do you feel that the chancellor needs to
come back to the public later on this
year perhaps early next year with with
additional measures
i think the chancellor will be hoping
that he's done enough for this year
so he he reacted yesterday to offgem's
announcement earlier this week where
they said what they thought the price
cap would be in the autumn and the
chance has taken that fully into account
so i think he and the treasury think
that the
the cash payments they're giving this
this this summer and the extra 200
pounds so 400 pounds total offer energy
bills also coming this autumn i think
they think that will be enough this
winter
crucially also the chancellor did
confirm that uh in in april uh he will
increase benefits and the state pension
in line with the usual rules and that
means a really large increase of nine
percent
and so as well as i think as well as
announcing is enough to get through the
winter i think the treasury also hope
that they have
committed to increasing benefits and
state pension by a lot next spring and
that should get us through
the april 2023's price cap
so of course that right now is an
incredibly uncertain volatile time but
given the latest forecast of energy
prices i think the chancellor's hoping
he's done enough to get us through at
least until uh next spring
um mike just just a final kind of
reflection on on the tone that we had
from from the chancellor yesterday a
number of uh mr sunak's colleagues um
even publicly are suggesting that the
measures as announced were not
particularly conservative i understand
that that's not your priority you want
to see people at the bottom end of
society getting as much help as is
possible but but do you perhaps see the
the the truth in that characterization
say about the chancellor is that when he
does take measures he does tend to go
big uh we saw that of course in the
pandemic where he uh announced the most
dramatic scheme that the country's ever
seen in terms of subsidizing people's
incomes in the job retention scheme and
he spent hundreds of billions of pounds
supporting the economy there
so i think the chancellor has recognized
that it just would not be sustainable to
let people
slide into debt and destitution this
autumn and winter and he's responded to
the incredibly unusual times we find
ourselves in
mike brewer from the resolution
foundation great to see you this morning
thanks very much for joining us
uh still to come on sky news breakfast
we will be taking a much closer look of
course at the current outbreak of the
monkey pox virus where it started how
concerned you should be
and of course continuing to reflect uh
on the chancellor's statement at the
dispatch box yesterday does it help you
did you want more get in touch we'll see
after this
[Music]
let's return to the emerging outbreak of
monkey pox infections have been
confirmed in 19 countries around the
world now wales and northern ireland
reported their first cases on thursday
bringing the total number across the uk
to 90 in all let's get a little bit more
on this we're joined by dr susan
lieberman from the wildlife conservation
society good to see you this morning
daughter
can you just explain
why in your mind we have seen this this
outbreak of late monkey pox is nothing
new but perhaps this brand of monkey pox
might be
well monkey pox is nothing new it's been
known for about 40 years in in africa
why suddenly it's it's much more
transmissible and we're seeing it in
many more countries outside of africa
not that it isn't
africa is the world is incredibly
globalized the minute there's an
outbreak of some kind of of a new
disease or an old disease even we're all
globalized we're almost eight billion
people on our planet we learned the hard
way on that with covid19 the minute
something happens wherever it is in the
world it's 24-48 hours before it's
everywhere globalization is great it's
fantastic but what we need to look at
with these emerging diseases these
viruses is how to prevent them in the
first place rather than react once it
happens
well that begs the question then doesn't
it doctor i mean how do we prevent that
happening
well the monk epoxy disease we don't
know all the details about this this
current this current outbreak but it's
called zoonotic that means it came from
a spillover of a virus that was in a
wildlife to people and then is
transmitted between people that's the
same as covin 19 and what we need to do
is prevent that interface that contact
between people and wildlife we need to
close down markets where wild animals
are sold live as food we need to stop
destroying tropical forests we need to
move what's called upstream and prevent
these spillovers in the first place and
keep wildlife in the wild
is there though some supranational
organization via which we could get
those changes made on a global scale i
mean try telling the chinese to to start
shutting down the wet markets you know
get what try getting a u.n resolution to
shut down the wet markets
you might struggle
actually the chinese have shut down the
wet markets for food but there's a the
world health organization has launched a
process to develop a new treaty or
global agreement on pandemic prevention
preparedness and response but
governments are focusing more on
response oh my goodness what do we do
when it happens they need to include in
this treaty and there's meetings right
now in switzerland and this is going to
be negotiated over this year and next
year gov we need to all push governments
to prioritize prevention and to all
agree to quote not only to close down
the live markets for wildlife but to
also look at issues of destroying
tropical forests we do know how to
prevent but we need to governments need
to get their act together and do it
they they do and dr lieberman just a
final word from you briefly if you can't
because we're just about out of time
reassure those of us who see the words
monkey pox
on their screen and immediately panic
just provide some level of reassurance
if you can
don't panic first of all don't panic we
understand this disease although it's
it's transmissible between people those
who get it it's not it's not fatal
necessarily people need to isolate but
no don't panic at all
really
dr susan lieberman great advice and
thank you for providing it and thanks
also for your time this morning really
appreciate it
my pleasure thank you
now
previously unseen home videos of guess
who the queen have been released ahead
of our platinum jubilee celebrations
next week
stunning pictures aren't they uh well
the clips provide some touching glimpses
of the private life behind the crown and
indeed the queen mum and a pair of
sunglasses never seen that before her
majesty has also recorded a personal
message to introduce the new bbc
documentary elizabeth the unseen queen
it is quite something when you look at
these faces that you have known all your
lives uh all of our lives but back then
in the dress uniform as well yeah the
queen's father there of course uh we'll
have more on that in the next art of the
programme
and indeed we'll have much much more uh
in terms of reaction uh we interviewed
the chancellor at the top of the seven
o'clock hour this morning he told me his
plans to ease the cost of living crisis
will not have a knock-on effect on
inflation a minimal effect he suggested
he also suggested that we will be seeing
benefits and pensions rising in line
with inflation a huge package of
measures requires a lot closer
examination we will be speaking to rishi
sunak's opposite number of the shadow
chancellor after this
[Music]